et pour parler de la situation aux
etats-unis nous sommes avec jérôme
danard président du comité français
états unis bonsoir merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors la
sortie de l'hôpital du président donald
trump une sortie finalement très bien
orchestré oui nous sommes en plein dans
les élections américaines et donc le
j'irai quelque part on est devant le
show un spectacle vraiment à l'image de
ces élections américaines
tous les quatre ans nous avons des
candidats qui font tout pour attirer
l'attention des électeurs c'est un petit
peu le jeu ce qui est un petit peu
regrettable c'est qu'aujourd'hui on est
plutôt sur quelques veaux quelques
images et on parle très peu des
programmes et pourtant les programmes
entre programme démocrate et le
programme républicain
il ya de grandes différences et c'est
quand même ça qui est important puisque
les quatre prochaines années vont être
importantes tour les états unis ça
serait bien qu'on puisse recentrer le
débat plus sur les idées que partagent
ces deux candidats parce que c'est vrai
qu effectivement on a vu le président
américain donald trump retiré son masque
jo weiden nuit s'est exprimé toujours
avec un masque
est ce que finalement c'est cette
question du masque qui risque d'être
finalement la question numéro à les
jours prochains dans la campagne
honnêtement pour connaître les états
unis et les américains je pense
qu'aujourd'hui au moment où on se parle
il y à peu d'indécis dans l'électorat
américain
les américains pour moi ont fait leur
choix
maintenant il ya encore pratiquement 28
jours ou 27 jours avant la date at de
finale de cette élection pour connaître
le nom du prochain président mais ça
sera à mon avis un sans surprise pour ce
que ça représente pour les américains
aujourd'hui on a tendance à trop
regarder ces déchirements internes avec
le prisme français 1 c'est une élection
qui est très compliqué on est déjà dans
un suffrage indirect avec deux partis
dominants
on ne parle que du parti démocrate et du
parti républicain mais pourtant il ya
aussi des partis minoritaires dans
l'élection présidentielle c'est à leur
importance et donc c'est vrai que c'est
à la fois compliqué mais passionnant
c'est en tout cas c'est beaucoup de ces
sources d'interrogations et peut-être
aussi d'incompréhension de la part des
français donc c'est important de
resituer le débat alors on a vu donald
trump qui qui s'affiche en pleine forme
et il le dit je vais bien finalement
c'est sa stratégie pour ne pas paraître
fragilisé à mois d'un mois de l'élection
présidentielle et il peut pas avoir
notre discours
c'est le président des états unis et il
a été malade
aujourd'hui il doit avoir une parole
positive en disant vous voyez j'ai été
le touché j'ai été concernés maintenant
si vous aussi vous l'êtes
soyez forts et battez vous contre la
maladie
je pense que si joe biden ou un autre
une autre personne était à la place de
l'épreuve
le discours on était quand même
globalement le même alors est ce qu'on
en sait d'ailleurs davantage sur son
état de santé
est-ce qu'il est sorti en dépit de
l'avis des médecins
elle a écouté je peux pas répondre à
votre question je ne suis pas mais ça je
ne suis pas scientifique
est-ce que donald trump a outrepassé les
recommandations médicales que les
médecins ont pu lui proposer je ne peux
pas répondre je ne suis pas dans les
secrets de la maison blanche
en tout cas il est clair qu'aujourd'hui
le rhin trump rebondi sous un angle de
communication quand je vous disais il ya
quelques minutes
on assiste vraiment à un show à
l'américaine on est dans la dernière
ligne droite de ces élections
présidentielles donc tout est permis
il me semble que shaw weiden aujourd'hui
tweets des photos avec son son chien
donc oui et tout est fait pour attirer
l'attention alors dans le même temps
d'en parler des écoles de new york
1re ferme face à la hausse des cas
comment expliquer comprendre ce message
contradictoire
surtout quand donald trump finalement
appelle les américains à sortir alors ça
c'est ça fait parti des spécificités des
états unis 1 nous avons en fin de compte
50 et a un qui n ont un fonctionnement
normalement tous autonomes donc les
gouverneurs doivent gérer en fonction
des situations locales
là en l'occurrence il s'agit de la ville
de new york le maire a voulu s'engager
pour préserver la santé des new york et
c'est tout à son honneur
après il faut juste intégré que derrière
il ya quand même 10 arrière pensées
politiques
le maire de new york bill de blasio
avait des ambitions nationales
il ya un peu de temps au sein du parti
démocrate pour se présenter à l'élection
présidentielle
donc peut-être que c'est aussi pour
avoir un
on va dire devant de scène médiatique
par rapport à ce qui n'a pas pu obtenir
dans les primaires démocrates et avoue
avoir une existence plus politique pour
sa carrière dans les mois voire les
années à venir
merci beaucoup je dis rom d'un art pour
votre éclairage
je rappelle que vous êtes président du
comité france etats unis